well technically those words are Chinese
for water is benevolent and the other
say earth is strong fire is fierce and
air is harmonious why the omission Qatar
ater what exactly are you hiding also if
this is a different world from ours why
is the writing in our world's Chinese
and the spoken languages our world's
English this can only mean that this
actually takes place in this world but
sometime in the future and now I'm
sitting that I'm not already bending
things like Beckham reading I can't
believe I lost him normally this would
be pronoun gaming but this is a
continuation from part one so really
this is a sin on us for just sending
apart to besides anyone who watched part
one already knows she's talking about
her pet turtle duck scram Quackers Zuko
can't have gotten far
we'll find him Zuko is a perfectly fine
name for a villain but that's also a
name that is so tied into a certain
musical that every time I hear his name
said I'm reminded of the song greased
lightning and think that's just a
dangerous recipe for combustion what
kind of idiot tries to grease their
lightning yep ho I read your comments
and I watched your explainers and I'm
still sinning the fact that this
creature flies I mean look at how he
floats if he isn't as hollow as a
balloon at the Macy's Thanksgiving Day
Parade this is some great a bison
nightmare on aang street go away
[Music]
Yoda still here um yeah it's been two
seconds since you said go away even if
he turned immediately and sprinted you'd
still see him every video game ever this
character does not have an HBO max app
trying to outrun breaking ice cliche
three times multiplier added for using a
cliche that's been in a fast and furious
movie Zuko is now using the speak the
things you see exposition format comes
in handy when you think your audience is
too dumb to realize why a character
would want to find a cave in a snowstorm
thanks show oh they call him the face
stealer wait is Nic Cage in this I'm not
sure if I find that exciting or
terrifying kind of a sin either way I
guess you're like my sister everything
always came easier
she's a firebending prodigy and everyone
adores her POW d'emic ponytail here is
not only having a very basic villain
explains his backstory to the hero
moment but he's doing it with an
unconscious captive someone gets Zuko
some story Odia maybe because he has a
really bad case of explosive exposition
area it's really nice of those engaged
weapons to wait till they get to their
landing spot to cause any destruction no
random fire debris falling on innocent
bystanders caught in between and should
be in the advertising I assure you I
have everything under control I intend
to remove the moon as a factor remove
the moon when did this turn into a
terrible 60s bond rip off in like Zhao
you're just a curly-tailed Bluenose
sudden chochmah the shape-shifting
clownish face the nightmares form the
underground lair the fact that you
disabled the creatures powers by not
showing fear is Stephen King receiving
anything from the show dollar and
Pennywise I mean this snake scorpion
impede births faces through its head
fulva that's it that's the sin guess
we'll be here a while judd apatow movies
even Nickelodeon shows aren't immune to
amping up the peril by having a mom
clutching an infant as they run away
this battle started yesterday you ice
pricks you should have found that child
permanent shelter by now well hey bye to
you too rude also fun side note pandas
can be extremely dangerous and while
they wouldn't go out of their way to
kill a human I'm gonna say they wouldn't
let one jump on their back and frolic
off into the yonder either even the
magical hybrid spirit ones
so also pandas are thought by many to be
in the raccoon family and not in the
bear family because many people are
idiots
these Bend battles are so inventive this
show actually puts thought into how the
different elements would work in a
battle and it's one of the reasons it
will continue to melt sins from my ice
cold heart considering this seems to be
the most effective use of his powers why
didn't he lead with this the hybrid
animals in this world are fun
this one is apparently part monkey and
part ass with an emphasis on the ass
well that's convenient I mean it's also
cool but it's definitely convenient and
even being cool Fenian is a sin I also
see that the storm has suddenly vanished
just so we can have a clear shot at
seeing and hearing what's about to
happen yeah this makes a lot of sense
let's bring the guy who's constantly
trying to kill us as per usual Sokka
would be excellent at sin bending I feel
it too you need a feeling for that the
beet-red sky not enough of a clue I owe
the moon spirit my life ever I'm no
traitor Jo he is or isn't he can we just
make this Lake a
choose-your-own-adventure so I can
pretend I know what's going on no fine
carry on
but I'm watching the rest of this under
protest my moon spirit is not happy
[Applause]
so the avatar is like the guy who turns
your electricity back on after you've
paid up your past due notice it's my
duty Sokka I won't let you
I know Sokka desperately wants to be
your boyfriend and all but he did
hearing say no idea what kind of chaos
that would unleash on the world right
your father told me to protect you
a father who would put his daughter's
life in the hands of Sokka is well a
father who doesn't really give two about
his daughter's life I have to do this
that's awesome thanks for saving the
world and all but where exactly did you
learn how to transfer your life force
just moon spirit instinct I guess she's
God that's rough buddy and by always I
mean for the next three seconds or so
gucchi I'm surprised
Prince Zuko surprised that you are not
at this moment trying to capture the
avatar this guy he is supposed to be
all-knowing right so he should know that
there are less than two minutes
remaining of a season finale and without
a cliffhanger nobody would watch this
again okay fine maybe they would watch
it again but I want to know what happens
I mean you could jump in after him what
no swimsuit meet me to go buy you a
zucchini Oh
zucchini that's the good stuff obvious
hero shot is shot obviously I have a
task for you
siblings fish are friends not food
people be like I was there comment on
the video when it's just posted fans
feel like I'm a member of mother you
could be a [ __ ] member to get
videos early extra videos bonus podcast
swag discounts and Mo
click the patreon link in the
description or at cinemasins comm to
take your sin to the next level but I
believe Aang can save the world
go away they called him the face stealer
I'd like to take his his face oh you're
like my sister everything always came
easy to her she's a firebending prodigy
and everyone adores her Marsha Marsha
Marsha remove the moon oh just say the
word and I'll throw a lasso around and
pull it down it's been a long time you
know me can smell the circus Georgie
there's peanuts cotton candy hot dog
[Music]
it's my destiny to destroy the moon
that's not a moan
[Music]